[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour une nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 17 septembre tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal il
est le premier maire marcheurs de saint
quentin en yvelines stephen mirambeau a
annoncé son ralliement à la république
en marche
l édile de villepreux pourrait se
présenter sous l'étiquette
présidentielle dès les prochaines
élections municipales de 2020
explications et réactions dans cette
édition laisse montigny le bretonneux et
voisins fc au 4e tour de la coupe de
france de football
ils font partie des 14 clubs zibinoh a
qualifié l esi ni mon teint notamment
éliminé choisy-le-roi une équipe
évoluant trois divisions plus haut ce
résultat et bien d'autres encore à
suivre dans la chronique sport et puis
les journées européennes du patrimoine
se sont clôturés hier de nombreuses
sorties étaient proposés à saint quentin
en yvelines et aux alentours ont fait le
point en reportage et sur ce plateau
avec notre invité et jean-manuel
charreaux administrateur du château de
breteuil et puis à nous parlerons
également de l'estaca tout à l'heure
l'école d'ingénieurs à montigny le
bretonneux à se fixe de nouvelles
évolutions
en cette nouvelle rentrée emmanuel
macron dans les yvelines il est venu
samedi matin à bougival à la dila
viardot retenu parmi les 18 sites
prioritaires l'ancienne demeure de la
cantatrice pauline viardot elle va être
aidés grâce au loto du patrimoine le
président de la république a d'ailleurs
remis à samedi un chèque de 500 mille
euros signé par la française des jeux
de gros travaux de sécurisation sont
prévues à la ville a fermé depuis trois
ans au public à montant total 3 millions
d'euros estimé le lieu devrait rouvrir
début 2020 avec un projet d'envergure
forme et le centre européen de la
musique avec la maison voisine de bizet
à deux ans des élections municipales le
maire de villepreux a donc officialisé
son ralliement à la république en marche
élu sur une liste divers droite depuis
2008 stéphane denis rambaud est aussi
vice président en charge des finances à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et il souhaite rester dans la
majorité de droite intercommunale les
détails avec
nicolas d'android c'est le premier maire
saint quentinois à rejoindre le parti
des manuels macron stéphane mirambeau a
rendu public son adhésion à la
république en marche un ralliement
effectif depuis avril 2017
mais le maire de villepreux a choisi
délibérément son timing
j'ai attendu d'officialiser son
ralliement à un moment particulier
certains me disaient qu'il ne fallait
pas le faire parce qu emmanuel macron
baisser dans les sondages moi je pense
justement que c'est au contraire c'est
dans ces moments là qu'il faut soutenir
l'action du gouvernement est un
véritable relais expliqué qu'il faut une
europe forte et ne pas justement
défendre le repli sur soi comme
certaines listes vont sûrement le faire
la deuxième raison je veux soutenir
emmanuel macron dans ses réformes je le
pays mérite vraiment et a besoin d'être
réformé maires de villes pro depuis 2008
sur une liste divers droite réélu en
2014 dès le premier tour avec plus de
63% des voix
stéphane mirambeau suit les valeurs
d'une droite humaniste sociale est
ouverte
membre de la majorité de saint quentin
en yvelines il est vice président en
charge du budget sous une présidence de
rassemblement voulue par jean michel
fourgous
moi je dirais écouter dans la mesure où
ou
ne mets pas en cause la majorité
voilà moi il peut garder son poste faut
quand même que nos élus se sentent très
libre et vous savez j'ai toujours les
gens qui m'ont suivi moi ils me suivent
pas par soumission ils me suivent par
adhésion prochaine étape pour stéphane
mirambeau le soutien de la liste
lrm pour les européennes avant de
s'engager pleinement dans sa candidature
pour les élections municipales en 2020
cette école d'ingénieur est basée à
saint quentin en yvelines avec un campus
implantée à montigny le bretonneux et
renoncer en ces premières semaines de
septembre l'istac a évolué pour en
parler avec nous catherine forveille
avec nos soeurs plateau bonsoir parce
que vous êtes responsable du département
communication et marketing à l'estaca on
va parler de ces évolutions dans un
instant d'abord présentons cette école
d'ingénieurs qui est spécialisé dans les
domaines des transports mobilité
automobile voilà aéronautique et
spatiale c'est un secteur porteur
ce secteur des transports alors tout à
fait on a la chance effectivement d'être
sur un secteur avec beaucoup d'enjeu
pour demain avec des transports qui font
renouveler dans une problématique des
développement durable que tout le monde
connaît donc effectivement c'est un
secteur qui recrute beaucoup
d'ingénieurs avec beaucoup de beaux
défis à relever pour les jeunes qui
s'engagent dans cette voie là donc on
recrute pas mal d'étudiants passionnés
souvent c'est une école techs et cible d
après le bac tout à fait c'est une école
qui recrutent après le bac donc la
majorité des étudiants à l'estaca arrive
après une terminale s ou une terminale
sti 2d pour l'orne à quelques
possibilité d'admission ce qu'on appelle
nous les admissions parallèles donc pour
une entrée en deuxième troisième
quatrième année quand on a déjà commencé
un cursus soit de classes préparatoires
soit à l'université avec des passerelles
possibles mais le flux majoritaire
arrive de terminale et j'aimerais
rappeler que c'est une école
d'ingénieurs qui s'adresse aux garçons
et aux filles
il ya une vraie problématique de
recrutement de fans ingénieurs dans
notre dans nos domaines des transports
donc les entreprises font un appel aux
filles pour qu'elles viennent nombreux
aussi à l'estacade le message est passé
ces formations elles se font en cinq ans
sur sur ce campus de style tout à fait
donc ses déformations en cinq ans avec
les deux premières années forcément un
cycle plus tôt avec des matières
générales mathématiques physique
mécanique et puis qui se spécialise
petit à petit la filière ce que l'on
appelle la filière transport
c'est-à-dire le choix de faire plutôt
aéronautiques et spatiales plutôt
ferroviaire plutôt automobile se fait
dès la deuxième année
et puis après les étudiants pendant
quatre ans se spécialise sur cette
filière qu'ils ont choisie avec toujours
un tronc commun
donc ces filières sont finalement les
différentes formations qui sont proposés
par les strikers voilà qui sont les
quatre domaines que vous avez cités
automobile aéronautique spatial et
ferroviaire alors c'était la rentrée
récemment à l'estaca combien d'élèves
l'école accueille telle cette année sur
sur son site de saint quentin en
yvelines
alors on a accueilli au total de mille
cent quarante élèves et 1500 sur le site
de saint quentin en yvelines à montigny
est ce qu'il ya des nouveaux arrivants
alors on est
au total ces 360 nouveau admis dont deux
cents environ à saint quentin
est ce qu'il ya une évolution est ce que
vous avez plus d'étudiants qui rentre à
l'estaca cette année on a on a davantage
de candidats l'estaca attire
mais nous on essaie de rester sur des
groupes relativement stable donc on est
en évolution constante méga pas une
grosse augmentation cette année
utilisez une admission après le bac
c'est à dire que ces étudiants sont
passés par la case parcours sud pour
revenir se passait par là par la case
parcours super ça s'est relativement
bien passé pour nous on avait beaucoup
de candidats donc non ça s'est
relativement bien passé on a on est
satisfait en tout cas du recrutement
qu'on a fait avec un taux de mentions
bien et très bien qui est très fort
cette année on est au delà de 85 %
d'élèves qui qui rentre avec mention
bien ou très bien
trois évolutions majeures pour l'estac
en cette rentrée 2010 8 alors d'abord le
déploiement d'un centre d'ingénierie
pédagogique d'évaluation ce qu'on
appelle un ces ip eux ça sert à quoi
alors en fait à l'estaca on est toujours
dans l'innovation au niveau de la
pédagogie et donc on a mis en place il
ya déjà deux ans maintenant ce qu'on
appelle la pédagogie inversée l'objectif
est de rendre l'étudiant acteur de sa
formation ce qui veut dire qu'il sait
qu'il faut que ce qui se passe en cour
ce soit anticipée est donc un
environnement d'apprentissage numérique
a été mis en place avec la possibilité
pour l'élève de trouver en ligne des
supports de cours des vidéos des tests
de manière à aborder le court avant
d'avoir l'enseignant qui le lui délivre
de manière à s'autoévaluer pour savoir
quelles sont les difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent et de manière quand il ya ce
qu'ils arrivent en cours en ayant déjà
des questions à poser en sachant les
difficultés qui va rencontrer doter de
nouvelles pratiques pédagogiques c'est
dans le cadre de ces nouvelles pratiques
pédagogiques que le cpe a été mis en
place et va se développer cette année
avec également un objectif d'améliorer
l'évaluation des étudiants donc le e de
ces ip eux c'est pédagogique et
évaluation de manière à améliorer
l'évaluation est aussi de voir comment
faire évoluer en tant les pratiques dans
cette thématique de la pédagogie
également une autre évolution c'est
l'amélioration de l'encadrement
pédagogique et vous avez renforcé cette
année votre équipe pédagogique tout à
fait parce qu'on s'est rendu compte que
quand même la marche entre la terminale
et l'enseignement supérieur elle est
haute pour certains élèves
donc l'objectif c'est de mieux encadrer
les élèves notamment quand ils arrivent
en première année
on a réduit ce que nous on appelle les
cordes les groupes élèves ils sont
normalement maximum 50 par groupe et
donc pour accompagner ce ces groupes
plus petits on a recruté des enseignants
et aussi des responsables les
responsables de filières qui coordonne
les enseignements sur chaque dominante
donc aéronautique automobile ferroviaire
espace des 1ers ex eu d'évolution nous
reste un peu moins d'une minute c'est
développer de nouveaux partenariats à
l'international ça veut dire que l'estac
elle ne le faisait pas où le faisais pas
assez en tout cas on le fait depuis
longtemps l'expérience internationale
elle est obligatoire pour tous les
étudiants
là on a signé des nouveaux partenariats
à l'international ce qui permet d'ouvrir
le portefeuille et le champ des
possibles pour partir pour nos étudiants
et puis il ya un autre axe qui est
l'accueil des étudiants étrangers
et là dessus on a développé un une
formation diplômante avec l'inde pour
permettre à des étudiants indiens de se
former trois en inde puis de venir à
l'estaca avec un programme qu'on a conçu
ensemble pour les années où ils sont en
inde mais on peut retrouver bien sûr
toutes ces informations sur l'estac l
actualité également de cette école sur
son site internet
avec qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
merci à catherine forveille d'avoir été
avec nous merci je rappelle que vous
êtes comme une responsable de la du
département pardon communication et
marketing à l'estaca le sport la ryder
cup 2018 c'est dans presque une semaine
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'ici là nous
vous proposons chaque jour est de
découvrir le parcours de la compétition
ce soir
présentation du trou numéro un lieu
incontournable qui sera entouré par une
super tribune de 6800 place est
découverte avec michael et demi d'euros
et patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
bienvenue donc là on est au départ du
trou numéro un de la battre ossements
que parcours qui va accueillir
accueillir la ryder cup à la fin du mois
et on à commencer bien évidemment par le
trou numéro un trou numéro un qui va
être un endroit qu'un c'est particulier
parce que premier coup parce que
je sais pas si vous avez l'occasion de
voir mais vous avez à la derrière des
tribunes qui sont les plus grandes
construite sur sur aucune des riders que
précédente
il va alors un peu plus de 6000
spectateurs donc la pression du public
et la pression de ce trou qui est
également un trou qui m'est assez
difficile à jouer
selon même les mots de sergio garcia qui
a des trous les plus difficiles sur sur
le sur les sur les tournois du circuit
européen avec de l'eau assez
accueillante sur la partie gauche du
fairway et sur la partie droite du
fairway en rêve qui peut être très
pénalisant si toutefois la mise en jeu
était lâché un petit peu trop à droite
[Musique]
elle si on est sur la retombée on va
dire idéal de ce trou du marois donc là
admettons qu'on ait fait une mise en jeu
idéal ici le coup suivant reste quand
même assez délicat à jouer parce que
pourquoi parce qu'en fait c'est un green
qui est construit volant tout temps tout
en largeur d'accord avec assez peu de
profondeur
donc il va falloir choisir le bon club
parce que si le coût est trop court bien
évidemment le joueur sera pénalisé par
l'obstacle d'eau pieds devant si le coût
est trop long il ya deux magnifiques
banker qui qui attendent les balles
donc là on est sur le green du trou
demeurant un green sur lequel on a
engagé des travaux en amont la ryder cup
ça peut être très délicat s'il a loupé
le green seal est dans le bunker où dans
l'europe parce que la balle pour
l'arrêter sera difficile à arrêter avec
bien évidemment la punition de l'eau qui
sera qui sera derrière c'est ensuite
parce qu'en fait il ya des banques qu'on
voit pas forcément beaucoup sur ce green
l'a donc un pain à green à ces traîtres
sinon mise à part ceux mis à part cela
les positions de bras paul et plus elle
est plus facile seront les positions à
l'entrée parce que là les plantes sont
qu'un relativement relativement molle
mais il n'empêche que très honnêtement
la difficulté dans l' attaque de green
ce sera d'éviter les bunkers d'éviter
surf où il sera impossible à arrêter une
balle qui si malheureusement allait mal
touché finira dans l'eau et en attendant
la ryder cup la première manche de la
winery cup s'est déroulée jeudi dernier
à elancourt c'est une compétition
oenologique mettant aux prises non pas
les joueurs de golf et mais les
vignobles américains et européens
une opération à l'occasion de repas de
gala organisé par le réseau art partage
et au profit de l'association handigolf
le principe les participants au déguste
tout au long de la soirée six vins à
l'aveuglé doivent les départager
ensuite avec modération bien sûr est le
vainqueur sera désigné au bout de trois
manches
les propos sont collectées par patrick
jacques de dixmude je trouve l'idée
originale agréable
puisqu'elle permet aussi aussi un des
bateaux du log de régny beaucoup de gens
dans la convivialité est donc à nouveau
plein de bonnes raisons de venir à la
veux je veux dire ça va être pas être
évident tout le monde va va ramer mais
l'europe va gagner c'est évident on va
pas se faire battre par les américains
quand même mais a raté en tout cas pour
cette fois ce sont les états unis qui
ont remporté la première manche de cette
winer cup prochain round les 20 et 27
septembre prochains
[Musique]
le week-end a une nouvelle fois une
nouvelle fois été riche en actualités
sportives dans les yvelines a pour nous
présenter à ses principaux résultats
divino c'est une habitude désormais le
lundi dans le journal michael et demi
d'euro bonds soir en soir grégory je
suis ravie encore à chaque fois de vous
retrouver le lundi mois est également
alors vous êtes le journaliste au sport
de cette rédaction michael ont joué
notamment le 3e tour de la coupe de
france de football ce week-end oui
grigorian répète chaque année la coupe
de france fait rêver tous les
footballeurs français cette compétition
permet de voir des scénarios
rocambolesques ce week-end la magie
opérer du côté de monti le bretonneux
lésigny mon teint qui évolue en deuxième
division de district ont réussi à
renverser la montagne choisy-le-roi une
équipe de r de trois divisions au-dessus
le score 0 à 0 et sans tirs au but à 3
pour montigny le bretonneux
on écoute les réactions micro de notre
journaliste marylène heye à pishin on
est hyper content franchement j'ai pas
trop les mots parce que ça prendra pas
je visite de cette façon là et a du coup
à très heureux très heureux parce qu'on
retient c'est heureux
on a été solidaire et ça le foot et on
avait quand même l'objectif de se
qualifier on savait que ce serait se
serait pas facile mais au moins on
voulait on voulait pas juif juge ce
match on voulait chercher à se qualifier
voilà les joueurs ont fait les efforts
nécessaires ils ont été courageux et
solidaires pour pouvoir aller au bout
encore un grand bravo à montigny le
bretonneux tour d'horizon à présent des
principaux résultats de ce troisième
tour de coupe de france ce verset qui
évolue en n3 n'a eu aucun mal à
s'extirper du piège tendu par le club
d'ormesson l'équipe de d2 ce qu'en
finale à 6 à 0 de son côté le chine et a
failli réaliser l'exploit contre bagneux
mais s'incline à 3 2 c'est terminé
également pour bois d'arcy bailly noisy
équipe de d2 enfin l aventure continue
pour vélizy qui s'impose face à asnières
et voisins le bretonneux qui domine à
sèvres 1 à 0 au total il y aura 14 club
des yvelines au quatrième tour rendez
vous le dimanche 30 septembre prochain
mais bravo à tous nos yvelinois alors il
y avait aussi du handball ce week end
michael vous êtes incollables un grégory
1 sur l'actualité s'est saisie pour sa
première apparition de la saison dans le
championnat de nationale 3 plaisir s'est
imposé de justesse sur le terrain de
montfermeil sur le score de 25 à 24
en quête d'une montée cette saison les
plaisirs roissy on retrouve 4e après
cette victoire pour tenter de prolonger
cette bonne dynamique plaisir tentera de
remporter sa deuxième victoire samedi
soir prochain sur le terrain de saint
michel sport on termine par du basket
est ce que vous aimez les festival
offensif grégory ouioui plus tôt alors
c'est le gros score du week-end dans les
yvelines le club de le fc trappes neuf
et n'a pas fait de détail ce week-end
dans le championnat de nationale 3 les
trappistes ont pleinement réussi leur
entrée en lice en s'imposant regardez
bien le score grégory à 112 à 53 sur
leur terrain contre séguinière à saint
louis basket une véritable démonstration
résultat qui permet évidemment au
trappistes de prendre déjà la tête du
championnat merci michael pour ce tour
d'horizon est encore plus de résultats
sportifs à suivre on vous retrouve dans
quelques instants pour votre émission
est aux manettes du 7-8 sport c'est tout
à l'heure dans sur cette chaîne tv 78
sera-t-il l'arbre de l'année aux
clayes-sous-bois le platanes du parc de
diane représente l'île de france au 6e
concours de l'arbre de l'année plantés
il ya cinq siècles d'une hauteur de 30
mètres
il fait partie des 15 finalistes de
métropole et des dom tom l arbre de
diane et depuis 2000 classé comme
remarquable et doit son nom à son
instigatrice diane de poitiers favorite
du roi henri ii et vous avez jusqu'au 10
décembre pour voter sur le site du
concours de l'arbre de l'année
ce week-end d'ailleurs c'était les 35e
journée du patrimoine peut-être vous
êtes vous allé ses attentes et parler à
43 rendez vous saint quentinois
découverte de coulisses visites
d'expositions encore plongée dans
l'histoire
marylène iapichino et vous invite à l
ennemi d'euros est allé sur deux rendez
vous regardez à trappes
c'était une visite éclair mais non moins
chargées d'histoire avec une
participante inédite
josette et fille de cheminot elle a
grandi dans cette cité d'un bout à
l'autre des dents si c'était que des
enfants qui jouent et voilà c'est tout
les souvenirs qui reviennent les bons et
les mauvais il n'ya pas toujours que des
bandanas biblia 87 ans d'histoire
présentée par mme aimant de trappes les
dents de scie secret avec l'arrivée des
chemins de fer et au déploiement du
triage c'est un habitat qui a été conçu
spécialement pour eux et qui est issu un
peu de pas mal de courants
architecturaux et puis courant
hygiéniste aussi qu'ils vont se déployer
dans d'entre les deux guerres
c'est un artiste qui a beaucoup
travaillé pour saint quentin en yvelines
son style c'est un style figuratif comme
vous pouvez le voir et ses conseils et
composée en fait de 12 éléments peu près
les oeuvres de denis mondino décrypter
expliqué pour sa balade patrimoniale le
musée de la ville s'est placée sous le
signe de l'europe
il faut imaginer que saint quentin en
yvelines du temps de la ville nouvelle
du temps de l'édification au fait de
cette ville était un véritable champ une
page blanche pour tous ses artistes et
ses architectes qui venait collaborer à
l'édification de cette ville nouvelle
l'art public était associé dès le départ
de la création de la ville nouvelle sur
saint quentin en yvelines
martha panne de mondino ou encore
massimiliano fuksas ont été mis à
l'honneur
une dizaine de curieux ainsi pu
découvrir des problématiques de la
conservation et la préservation d'une
oeuvre très surpris parce que je passe
régulièrement mais effectivement des
j'ignorais tout ce qui se passe derrière
et tout ce qui est autour de la
restauration et d'entretien des oeuvres
ça m'a bien on vient me fait découvrir
marmont
mon territoire parce que vraiment il ya
des endroits je n'étais pas du tout pour
ces journées européennes du patrimoine
une trentaine de l'ue ont ouvert leurs
portes le temps d'un week end on élargit
la zone géographique mais on continue de
parler de ces journées européennes du
patrimoine avec mon nouvel invité jean
emmanuel charlot bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes à l'administrateur du château de
breteuil où est le cousin adieux marqués
breteuil alors votre site comme d'autres
qu'on a vu dans cette édition on parti
c'est votre site a participé pardon à
ces journées européennes du patrimoine
c'était un programme assez riche qui
était proposé hier
visite guidée du château les scènes de
comptes présence de conteuse est
également un grand bal napoléon iii
la météo était au rendez-vous il faisait
beau hier est ce que les visiteurs sont
venus sont venus très nombreux
je crois que le bal a effectivement
attiré beaucoup de monde c'est tous les
ans à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine un grand bal qui attire et
qui plaît à énormément de personnes
l'association carnet de bal vient avec
entre 50 et 70 danseurs tous costumés
il y avait des crinolines absolument
magnifique et des uniformes très beau
aussi fière et les danseurs invitent les
visiteurs qui souhaitent apprendre
quelques pas de danse les valses les
polkas comme on lit lancé à l'époque de
napoléon iii
parfois c'était une autre époque
napoléon iii d'ailleurs mais il ya 7 et
un bal second empire et donc les vins
les visiteurs sont invités à participer
sur le parquet a dansé avec les
professionnels ou semi-professionnels
est ce que ces journées du patrimoine
c'est on imagine une bonne occasion de
lancer la rentrée l'automne au château
de breteuil est-ce que c'est aussi
primordial pour pour votre site ces
journées du patrimoine oui parce que
beaucoup de visiteurs profitent de ce
week end là pour sortir avec les enfants
leur faire découvrir le patrimoine de
leur région
souvent le château n'est finalement qu'à
15 20 kilomètres de chez eux mais c'est
voilà c'est l'occasion de venir même si
breteuil est ouvert tous les jours toute
l'année ça reste en tout cas parfois une
première une amorce donc ça donne envie
bien sûr de revenir à toutes les saisons
il ya des très belle déco de noël
on fait les grandes fêtes pour pâques
voilà ça donne l'idée aux familles et
l'envié de venir
bonne journée du patrimoine est ce que
l'était la saison estivale a aussi été
bon pour pour le domaine de breteuil le
château de breteuil il a fait très chaud
est ce que ça a peut-être les plus
froides y aller les états est correct
compte tenu de deux éléments
effectivement la coupe du monde déjà qui
est sûre début de l'été ralentissez un
petit peu l'activité touristique
et puis effectivement la grosse chaleur
qui a découragé je pense certains alors
que dans le château il faisait très
frais mais bon voilà dans le star c'est
vrai une occasion qui sera évidemment un
peu plus chaud on a même eu des
annulations des centres de loisirs qui
ne souhaitait pas sortir les enfants par
ces grosses chaleurs donc voilà une
légère baisse effectivement de
fréquentation mais dans l'ensemble l'été
a été très correct on le sait c'est un
site familial le château de breteuil
avec son château bien sûr ses jardins
ses scènes de compte là dans les
prochains mois qu'est ce qu'il ne faut
pas rater au château de breteuil
alors il ya plusieurs dimanches à
l'automne qui vont être des temps forts
le 30 septembre il y à une pièce de
théâtre la belle et la bête
elle a déjà été jouée le 1er juillet et
elle a été très très applaudie donc
voilà on a cette deuxième représentation
le 30 septembre le 14 octobre il y aura
non pardon la pièce de théâtre c'est le
14 et 14 autres oui pardon le 30
septembre ce sont les escrimeurs
d'espérer spectacle d'escrimé artistique
dans le parc dans les cours d eau la
cour des écuries dans la cour du château
ou autour du miroir d'eau dans les
jardins à la française
il ya des petites scènes de cape et
d'épée et là aussi ce sont deux
démonstrations un peu comme des leçons
des scream et ça passionne les visiteurs
pas que les petits garçons tous les
visiteurs et tout ce programme on le
retrouve bien sûr sur le site internet
du château de breteuil
voilà et puis lors les deux les deux
vrai temps fort ce sera les deux
premiers week-ends et vacances de
toussaint
un premier week end donc le 20 et 21
octobre cinq compagnies vont
reconstituer des événements historiques
militaires et 12 auront cinq période
représentait ça va des templiers jusqu'à
la seconde guerre mondiale en passant
par la bataille de fontenoy ou les
grenadiers de napoléon
tout ça va tirer du canon défilé sonné
du clairon il campe il va ailleurs le
bivouac
donc il ya aussi les les cantinières les
feux de camp donc ça sur deux sur deux
jours ce week end ça va être très riche
historiquement parlant
et puis le week end du 27 28 octobre
nous aurons une grande expo playmobil
dans l'orangerie du château de breteuil
voilà énormément de playmobil environ
300 personnages qui vont reconstituer
des scènes d'histoire et des scènes des
contes de perrault
merci jean emmanuel charlot d'avoir été
avec nous mais je vous en prie
initiateur du château de breteuil à
choisel merci nous restons dans la
vallée de chevreuse pour refermer ce
journal avec un autre site c'est le
château de la madeleine qui attire
également les curieux en ce week-end des
journées du patrimoine sur place est les
visites se font entre histoire et
botanique découverte avec jules colle
ici
construit entre le 11e et le 14e siècle
sur les hauteurs de chevreuse pour
contrôler la voie paris chartres le
château de la madeleine attire
aujourd'hui de nombreux curieux
guidés par stéphane loriot petits et
grands découvrent une période
passionnante abordée sous différentes
facettes
on l'a fait de la botanique on a parlé
de vie comment dire davy cotiser en
terme de com on joue comme on dormait
ton comment camaro bataille est comment
se soigner etc et on a compris que le
moyen âge est une période extrêmement
riche que ce sont des renaissances voilà
successives et que la vie quotidienne au
moyen-âge basse et ça nous permet de
comprendre un peu plus de loubieng ou 20
les moines avaient des livres très
ancien qui leur confiait donc il y avait
cette force d'avoir des bouquins en plus
mais globalement le médiéval de manière
globale vraiment il avait une
connaissance botanique qu'aujourd'hui on
a vraiment vraiment perdu et qu'on
s'acharne pour certains a retrouvé une
connaissances botaniques que stéphane
initié au groupe de visites notamment
leur présentant les bienfaits de la
médecine par les plantes
leur titre ou la médecine moderne
commence un petit peu arrivent à
saturation je dirais et la médecine par
les plantes ou se nourrir avec des
plantes sauvages c'est revient au goût
du jour
pas que pour un effet mode pas parce que
c'est rigolo pas parce que c'est gratuit
nan parce qu'effectivement on pratique
une résilience vraiment vraiment
intelligente qui nous permet de
s'affranchir de traitement qui n'ont
plus cours parce que dangereux avec des
dégâts collatéraux que nos couleurs a
quasiment jamais avec les plantes
sauvages donc pour des pathologies
légères moyennes ou même lourdes les
plantes seront toujours là pour nous
accompagner tout le temps vous prenez
pour faire court trois plantes très
basique très connus comme l'ortie la
berce et le pissenlit est assis ne
fallait manger que ça sur une année à ne
faire que ça pour s'amuser à 5,6 et le
terme nous n'aurions aucune carence
alimentaire
toutes ces plantes sauvages autour de
nous sur lesquels nous piétaille on l'a
elles sont réelles nous colle ses plans
qu'elles sont vraiment à notre service
est bien profitons-en comprendre la vie
médiévale tout en faisant la
connaissance de plantes sauvages scène
et ne produisant aucun dégât collatéral
dans leur consommation
voilà de quoi satisfaire tous les
visiteurs du château
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]